[Música]
olá tudo bem com vocês
hoje eu vim aqui pra colocar o bode na
sala está a gerar uma sensação de
desconforto
nós estamos na era digital onde tem tudo
na nossa mão
eu quero uma comida ela vem eu quero um
carro para me levar ela vem
estamos na era das máquinas mas vocês
sabem como comandar a máquina mais
bonita e mais perfeita mas também a mais
complexa
vocês sabem como comandar a máquina
humana
essa sim é a mais bonita mas é a mais
complexa
vocês estão preocupados em ter coisas ou
em serem pessoas melhores
as empresas estão preocupadas com o
comportamento do cliente como atrair o
cliente gasta milhões em treinamentos
técnicos mas elas estão preocupada em
fazer com que as suas pessoas estejam
felizes e sejam pessoas melhores como
conduzir essa máquina tá doente
essa máquina está triste essa máquina
tão angustiada ela está precisando de
ajuda e gente tem que gostar de gente
gente tem que defender gente
outro dia eu vi uma camisa que dizia
quando mais eu conheço o ser humano mas
eu gosto do cachorro eu adoro animais
mas eu gosto de gente
eu gosto de ser humano só que ele está
triste no mundo corporativo
ele está com algumas doenças ele está
cheio de vaidade
ele estava dissimulada ele não consegue
falar a verdade um sistema de opressão
ele tava vítima de uma situação ele não
consegue ser protagonista
ele não sabe resolver o problema e ele
tá relativo porque ele tem medo
todos esses sentimentos ruins ele não
faz propósito ele está sentindo isso é o
que eu chamo dos mini miss do mundo
corporativo
completamente possíveis da gente
desfazer da gente deixa as pessoas mais
felizes e é por isso que o mundo
corporativo é mole ele é chato e pesado
que resolvi fazer ele ficar alegre ficar
feliz fica leve fazer as pessoas
entenderem que a gente passa a maior
parte do nosso tempo trabalhando e que
tem que ser legal que são a gente tem
que rezar para ter outra vida tem que
ser legal e dá pra ser legal e é por
isso que eu criei o movimento
#foramicarla leves
vamos ser mais práticos vamos ajudar uns
aos outros não vamos ter esses
sentimentos e por quê porque esses
sentimentos
esses hábitos essas manhã essa maneira
de agir
dá nisso daqui se você for ver como tal
mundo corporativo hoje você vai ver a
revista negócio angústias doce ou 11 dos
diretores da empresa estão doentes
eles estão indo para o hospital
e por que que eles estão assim porque se
eu quero fazer bem feito faço é mesmo
faço eu mesmo afinal não tem mais
ninguém inteligente do que eu então
centralizo deixo tudo pra mim sim fico
doente ainda devo resolveu dizer o
seguinte vocês não acreditam que as
pessoas precisam ser felizes trabalhando
para engajar e para produzir mais
eu vou valor a isso pra você ela calcula
que no brasil a gente pede 42 bilhões de
dólares anual pela nossa em
produtividade
aquilo que a gente faz em uma hora um
americano fazem 15 minutos
você vai ver o valor econômico colocou
nós somos educados para falhar na
carreira
nós somos robôs à espera de manutenção
em ambiente assim ninguém inova em
ambiente assim as pessoas não agregam a
destruição de valor dos insatisfeitos
o que um insatisfeito faz
o satisfeito nunca consegue consertar
se os tem que sair de cima do muro e tem
que começar a entender que o maior
patrimônio de uma empresa são suas
pessoas e tem que começar a cuidar delas
prazer meu nome é érica linhares a minha
vida começa no interior de minas gerais
eu tinha 15 anos e eu era miss chegava
na escola se ano
meu pai era muito rico
na época ele tinha um escort xr3 pra
quem não sabe
era como se fosse uma ferrari hoje eu
chegava de scott conversível eu era o
máximo
um belo dia meu pai chega em casa e diz
vale
não tenho mais nenhum tostão errei
porque as pessoas falham
só que ele de forma muito objetiva disse
temos que começar de novo o meu pai
começou de novo numa garagem no fundo da
meta de uma casa em que ele alugou a
minha mãe tem uma doença muito séria pra
vocês terem noção ela tomar morfina ela
sente dou todos os dias
todos os dias ela pegou uma carrocinha
de cachorro-quente foi principal praça
da cidade e foi vender porque ela
precisava de dinheiro para pagar o plano
de saúde
os meus irmãos foram vivem de talão de
estacionamento todos mais novos do que
eu
uma escadinha e eu na economia informal
comecei cedo sacoleira vendendo roupa e
vendia muito de lá comecei fui para o
sistema público com onde as pessoas
falam da prosperar
ninguém quer trabalhar ninguém quem eu
queria eu dei recorde é de arrecadar a 1
na prefeitura de sete lagoas da
prefeitura eu decidi para o sistema
privado comece de novo do zero pois e
atendente de loja e nessa empresa que eu
comecei como atendente de loja no setor
privado eu saí da empresa como diretora
nacional de uma das maiores empresas de
tecnologia deste país a tim
com 63 milhões de clientes uma empresa
de tecnologia predominantemente
masculina
eu era a única nesse patamar a única
mulher eu saí hoje só tem homens e aí eu
saio dali e monta uma empresa
montei a minha empresa que menos de um
ano é muito bem sucedida sempre por ter
resultado sempre sempre fui muito
próspera e prosperidade não está ligada
dinheiro tá ligada orgulho eu sentir
prazer e orgulho daquilo que eu faço
agora comunica como você deu tanto
resultado assim porque educando esqueci
de contar pra vocês eu sou pedagoga
eu exerço é o dom de educação de ensinar
às pessoas
essa história de que manda quem pode
obedece quem tem juízo isso não funciona
e se é pra quem não é dono de si
isso é pra quem não acredita no outro e
se é pra quem tem que usar a autoridade
eu como educadora eu tinha o princípio
de educaã ajudar da mão eu não queria
fazer pedagogia eu queria psicologia eu
eu pegava mais calma eu pegava os
bebezinhos as minhas bonecas e tratava
as minhas bonecas mas na minha cidade só
tinha pedagogia e eu disse na minha vida
ser grata a tudo e qualquer oportunidade
que me dão se a pedagogia que eu tenho
que eu vou fazer eu vou fazer bem feito
porque tudo ensina a gente aprende com
tudo
o desperdício é você fazer qualquer
faculdade ou entrar em qualquer escola
ou qualquer trabalho e fazer mal feito é
você que perde seu tempo
só você e à pedagogia foi quem fez eu
chegar onde estou hoje
nesse palco do ted e sou muito grato
eu aprendi
quem tem filho aí como eu que a gente já
seqüela os nossos filhos e esta sequela
linhas depois a gente pega onde no
ambiente de trabalho e tem que educar
adulto sim a gente desenvolve pessoas
até 80 anos as pessoas melhoram as
pessoas se engajam basta você dá atenção
basta você se interessar genuinamente
por elas pasta você simplesmente gostar
de gente e foi isso que eu fiz
por isso que eu dê resultado a minha
vida inteira porque eu não fiz sozinha
eu fiz com a minha equipe quando eu
estava na prefeitura foi com os meus
meninos adolescentes a gente deu o
recorde de arrecadação quando eu estava
na empresa quando eu tava na iniciativa
privada o que eu percebi que elas 15 mil
pessoas que passavam sobre o passado
sobre a minha gestão eu percebi o
seguinte eles que prosperavam não
necessariamente tinha a mesma grade
curricular mas tinham a mesma atitude
diante da vida e eu comecei a ver as
atitudes que eles tinham e comecei a
ensinar as pessoas até aquelas atitudes
aquele comportamento eles aprenderam
eu tinha a equipe mais feliz da empresa
a testada pela revista exame que faz
essa pesquisa
eu tinha equipe que dava resultados
exponenciais felizes eu tinha
funcionários que desde o estagiário ao
diretor das pessoas que pensavam em
marketing estrategicamente em trade as
pessoas que vendiam na rua aos que davam
suporte pessoas completamente distintas
do sul ao norte com culturas
completamente diferentes mas todas
queriam sim que alguém desce à mão que
ensinasse porque eles estavam prontos a
aprender e é só dessa maneira que a
gente faz com que as pessoas se engajem
com que elas produzam e que as empresas
tenham resultado exponenciais
vamos tirar esse bode na sala por isso
que está mandando língua pra mim que é
perfeitamente possível tirar dá pra ser
um país de ponta da produzir mais
o que a gente produz dá pra ser feliz e
próspero trabalhando como mudando o
comportamento das pessoas
eu não estou dizendo que técnica não
vale
seria uma heresia da minha parte sou
pedagoga e estou dizendo que técnicas em
comportamento é desperdício e
comportamento evolui e comportamento a
gente aprende
então sabe aqueles minis que eu falei lá
na frente pra vocês tá pra combater um
por um de maneira leve com amor com
cuidado como se combate a vaidade
ensinando as pessoas que ninguém faz
nada sozinho nesta vida ninguém
você precisa dos seus funcionários você
tem que cuidar deles
você tem que ensinar a eles você tem que
estar do lado deles
você precisa dos seus pares uma empresa
não funciona sozinha ela precisa de
marketing ela precisa de vendas ela
precisa de suporte ela precisa de rh e
todos têm que estar juntos
um dia você ajuda um dia você será
ajudado todos juntos essa competição
leonina de gente matando gente não leva
a gente em lugar nenhum você precisa
acelerar o seu chefe a mais era que eu
não gosto do meu chefe empresa empresa
coisa prática você não tá ali pra gostar
de ninguém
você não escolhe com quem você vai
trabalhar você chega lá as pessoas estão
escolhidas ali tenha delícia do
exercício da tolerância da empatia de se
colocar no lugar do outro e saber que
existem pessoas que pensam diferente de
você não tem essa história mas não gosto
de negro mas não gosto de mulher aí mas
não gosto de gay não interessa ali
dentro só interessa uma coisa só um
julgamento performance
se a pessoa entrega se ela agrega o
resto é um juízo de valor seu fique com
ele pra você não cabe isso dentro de uma
organização dentro da empresa
você tem sim que ser leal a empresa ele
é o seu chefe
gostando ou não se ele não te pedir pra
fazer nada que fere os seus princípios
aquilo que você se comprometer
eu a fazer você tem que fazer isso e
lealdade
então você tem que aprender que para
você ser feliz no ambiente de trabalho
você faz parte de um todo
você tem que ser leal ao seu chefe você
tem que ser parceiro dos seus pares e
você tem que cuidar dos seus
funcionários
quando você entende isso você deixa a
vaidade de lado
você entende que você não é uma pessoa
você é uma pessoa que faz parte de um
todo tem que acabar com a dissimulação
a gente tem medo de falar a verdade a
gente tem medo do debate porque o debate
a coisa mais rica do mundo eu não sei se
o papai ea mamãe de vocês disseram pra
vocês que vocês são as pessoas mais
incríveis do mundo
desculpa não são existem pessoas muito
melhores que vocês por aí vamos executá
las
vamos aprender com elas gênios são
poucos
o resto está na média e as pessoas vão
pensar diferente de você e você vai dar
a sua opinião e vai escutar uma opinião
diferente isso é rico e isso é lindo e
quando as pessoas entendem isso elas
começam a entender que a cada debate
elas saem mais ricas mais inteligentes
mais produtivas e que isso não é briga
isso é simplesmente uma discussão de
ideias onde pessoas pensam diferente e
tá aí a riqueza da vida a gente tem que
ensinar as pessoas a falar o que elas
pensam não é uma verdade absoluta
mas é o que ele pensa não pode simular
falar pra agradar ea gente tem que
ensinar as pessoas escutarem a entender
que elas não são donas da razão
se não tem que ganhar discussão
você tem que aprender numa discussão
vitimismo a gente tem que tirar essa
coisa essa carga que a gente tem de
vítima existem pessoas que precisam de
assistência o óbvio que existem estão
abaixo da linha da pobreza e todos nós
temos que ajudar e fazer algo mas
existem várias outras que não não
precisam elas precisam se tornar
protagonista da vida delas entender que
elas são
totalmente capazes é mais difícil para
uns do que para outros o óbvio que é eu
não estou dizendo que é igual para todo
mundo porque não é
não vamos ser hipócritas eu só estou
dizendo que dá que dá e não a mensagem
não pode ser diferente
a mensagem não pode dizer se você nasceu
assim nesse lugar com essa
característica sua vida acabou não nem a
hipocrisia de dizer que é igual e nem a
tragédia de dizer que não dá da toma o
volante da tua vida e siga em frente
porquê da não se faça de vítima
a gente tem que tirar também é ensinar
as pessoas a resolverem problemas
problema inerente à vida uns tornam ele
obstáculo outros tornam ele o desafio e
tá aí a diferença de quem é feliz
infeliz aquele que torna o problema e
desafio toda vez que ele resolve da
endorfina dentro do sangue dele e ele se
sente cada vez mais potente mais potente
mais potente aquele que transforma o
problema dele em obstáculo ele
transforma aquilo numa grande muleta uma
grande desculpa e não realiza nada e vai
se sentir sempre foi cassado e cada vez
pior e cada vez pior
problemas são inerente à vida temos três
tipos de problema os que não têm solução
solucionados estão os que a gente
inventa e tem que parar de inventar
problema e os que são problemas reais
têm que resolver é só isso vamos
simplificar a vida não compliquem a vida
reatividade as empresas hoje não querem
que as pessoas se adapta ela quer que a
pessoa nova como é que uma pessoa vai
inovar num ambiente de medo de opressão
que ela não pode ter uma idéia porque
ela não pode errar só é mandado embora
ninguém nova sim atrás de uma inovação
tem erros calculados responsáveis mas
tem as pessoas estão tentando em
opressão não se inova em opressão não
tem país de ponta não tem empresa de
ponta não tem
é preciso fazer as pessoas têm qualidade
de vida para oxigenar o cérebro para
levar o filho na escola para tomar um
chope com os amigos é necessário se não
não inova
pessoas estressadas angustiados e com
medo não inova são reativas elas têm
medo e por que que a gente tem que
preocupar com o comportamento
as pessoas têm que pensar muito mais em
ser pessoas melhores do que em ter
coisas elas gasto muito dinheiro
comprando coisas e pouco em tentando ser
pessoas melhores não ter aquele
sentimento
as empresas gastam milhões com o
comportamento de cliente e desempenho
técnico esquecem de investir no
comportamento do seu funcionário e
porque a gente tem que fazer isso porque
a gente gosta de gente porque a gente
tem que gostar de gente ajudar a gente
mas se você não fizer por causa disso
faça porque você funcionário vai ser uma
pessoa mais feliz mais engajado e mais
próspera porque todo mundo vai se ajudar
porque você vai pensar mais leve e você
empresa faça porque um funcionário feliz
engajado produz mais e você vai ter mais
lucro
enfim um último recado que eu quero
dizer para vocês sejam gratos gostem do
que tem pra hoje
se é isso que tem faça bem feito e lute
por aquilo que você quer agora se você
não fizer o que você tem hoje bem feito
se não chega aonde você quer
estou eternamente grata destaque hoje
muito obrigado por ter conseguido passar
a mensagem pra você
[Aplausos]
obrigada tchau tchau
[Música]